[Music]
right here with reaction on this
important news day is the author of the
best-selling book called vengeance
former Speaker of the House Fox News
contributor Newt Gingrich you have a
trump hating Hillary loving guy
exonerating Hillary before the
investigation and you see what happens
with general Flynn and all of Muller's
team of misfit toys of you well in this
Christmas season with corruption and a
lack of ethics I really believe this is
a danger to this country and equal
justice under the law nobody in the
media talks about it sir
well no I think two things one I don't
think I fully appreciated until this
evening how really important it was for
Donald Trump to win if Hillary Clinton
had won none of this would have surfaced
they just kept covering up all the
corruption and they would have just kept
taking care of themselves so the very
fact that you had this disruptive figure
in the White House all of us are
learning some pretty horrifying things
about how sick the system is how sick
the entire process is in ways I would
have thought were impossible mean I have
the greatest respect for the Federal
Bureau of Investigation and it is
astonishing to me that you could have
people at the top who are this corrupt
this profoundly dishonest the second
thing that struck me listening actually
to your opening monologue if you take
what general Flynn is accused of and
then you take virtually anything
Hillary's done
I mean 33,000 deletions of emails
without any kind of approval although
the view have having a totally
inappropriate server that was totally
outside the State Department rules I
mean it's just go down the list any one
of her things would certainly have at
least matched accusing general Flynn of
how can it be possible
you don't finish an investigation and
you're writing an exoneration and this
Trump hater pro-hillary guy is in the
heart of all of this
something is radically wrong if you
believe in equal justice under the law
you know my granddaughter Maggie just
got me to read a fascinating book about
murderers in Osage County Oklahoma in
the 1920s and part of what comes through
that book is everybody locally was
corrupt the sheriff was collapsed the
judges were co-opted I mean nobody could
get any kind of decency and that
actually is the case that J Edgar Hoover
used to begin building the modern FBI in
the sense of an honest integrity filled
you know serious investigative agents
it's a fascinating book but what struck
me was we now have the corruption that
that book describes at the very center
of our national capital there think
about Comey Comey decides to interview
Hillary Clinton not under oath so even
though I know what she said for I think
for hours none of it happened to general
the exoneration letter was already she's
never under oath generation might as
well drop ya you know you have a
best-selling book it's ripped from the
headlines here your book of vengeance
which I'm almost done with and it's a
great book you're a great writer and I'm
thinking you can't even make this up
when you think this is the United States
of America our mutual friend Mark Levin
calls us a post constitutional republic
this is now becoming a banana republic
if this stays my question where do we go
from here knowing what we now know well
I mean what I would seven out what I
would say is I haven't given up on
America I don't think Donald Trump's
even a figment I'm not saying this is
scary most of our viewers have it so
what we now know is the swamp is sicker
more corrupt more dishonest than we
thought it was so we just have to dig
deeper throw the rascals out we have to
recognize the election of 2018 is going
to be truly historic
because it's going to be between a
radical left that is stunningly corrupt
and the rest of us and we have to
understand that this is a real fight for
whether or not America is going to
remain a republic that is ruled by law
and the closet as soon as you generate
and into being a you know a purely
corrupt system of power where if you're
on the right team you can rip everybody
off and be protected and if you're on
the wrong team you can be innocent and
still go to jail and I think that's how
serious and how profound this is right
now it's one of the great historic
moments in American history it's a
chilling one too and I will fight to my
dying breath as you will I'm not giving
up but I am very deeply concerned
tonight mr. speaker thank you